this christmas millions of americans are
facing financial crisis with federal
unemployment benefits set to run out
tomorrow and right now that covet relief
bill is in florida where president trump
is spending christmas
so he can sign it but it's unclear right
now if he'll do that
earlier this week you remember he said
he may not sign it unless lawmakers
increased
the stimulus payments from 600 to 2
thousand dollars
believe it or not democrats agree
with the president at least to the
extent that we need to sign this bill
now
congress returning monday for a rare
late december session after republicans
blocked democrats effort to push through
that payment increase well without the
bill signed the state's unemployment
department says hundreds of nevadans
will lose out on their money
starting tomorrow theater officials say
they were fully prepared to implement
the relief bill
but they say now their hands are tied
the department says it's now virtually
impossible to avoid any gap in benefits
anybody receiving benefits from nevada
can still file weekly claims
those applying for the pua program will
eventually get caught up on payments
after the delay